my name is Jason calorie I'm an
astronomer here at the Space Telescope
Science Institute in Baltimore Maryland
I received an offer a job offer to come
and work at the Space Telescope Science
Institute in 2008 and when I came here
it was just a few months before the last
servicing mission to Hubble and this was
the most challenging servicing mission
astronauts had to go up and fix two of
the instruments on Hubble that were
broken and installed two brand-new
instruments in Hubble and those
instruments were gonna extend Hubble's
vision both to the ultraviolet and to
the infrared it was already a rock star
in the visible light Channel but we were
gonna push it in both extremes right
after we installed this new instrument
this new camera on Hubble I was a part
of a large team that executed one of the
biggest Hubble Space Telescope programs
ever and the goal of the program was to
look at another galaxy the Andromeda
galaxy and actually see the galaxy as a
collection of hundreds of millions of
stars that's what a galaxy is and so we
use the full power of Hubble to peer
deep into this galaxy and break up its
stellar populations into individual
components and so with the increased
resolution on Hubble we're able to see
stars individual stars in this galaxy
that are separated by light-years so the
same distance between the Sun and the
nearest star to the Sun we can see that
scale in this other galaxy across one
corner of the entire galaxy and we
measure hundreds of millions of stars we
can see the hot stars that are shining
in the ultraviolet we can see the cool
stars that are shining in the infrared
and we can put together a complete
picture of how stars form and evolve and
how galaxies are shaped through that
image
you